welcome back everyone we did get a
little bit of a teaser recently so i did
an updated version for you i put
together every single scene uh in order
by plot league so far so it's a little
more comprehensible when it comes to uh
the entire movie itself uh so let's get
started please subscribe if you haven't
by the way i would really appreciate
that we're so close to 1 000 which is a
huge milestone all right let's go
first
the nightmare begins
we'll walk through it
[Music]
with the stability of space-time
[Music]
wonder
i knew sooner or later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories other avengers
i'll get you back in the lunchbox
but i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
hope you understand no pressure then
who or what
you break the rules
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry steve
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
greatest threat
[Music]
what do you know about the multiple
between universes
and we don't know
your desecration of reality
i dreamed the same dream
[Music]
is you
things just got out of hand
meant for ready
did what i had to do
this path exacts a heavy toll
[Music]
the multiverse
depends on us
and that's pretty much it guys thank you
so much for watching it looks like
that's pretty much the closest that
we've gotten to the end of the movie uh
but i'll do an updated version if we do
get anything uh from marvel uh do me a
favor again please subscribe if you
haven't i'd really appreciate it we're
so close to a thousand uh huge milestone
thank you so much see you guys tomorrow